- $50 cheddar cheese?
- The (bleep), this (bleep) better, like,
make me lost 10 pounds and
clear up my acne scars.
(singer vocalizing in foreign language)
- I love cheddar.
Cheddar's a great cheese.
Also, if you're lactose
intolerant, like me,
cheddar's a good cheese because there's
very low lactose in it.
- We're both in a cheese
club, believe it or not.
- We're in a cheese club together.
- So, (mumbles) if you're
lactose intolerant.
- I'm so sorry.
- I don't trust you if
you don't like cheese.
- The cheapest and the most expensive,
love 'em both.
- I like Kraft singles.
I like cheap American cheese.
I like fancy, soft cheese.
I like hot cheese.
I like cold cheese.
- There's no way I'm gonna be able to tell
the difference between cheap
cheese and expensive cheese.
- What do you put $50 cheese on?
- First and foremost,
you can definitely tell
that this cheese aerated.
- Smells like Cheetos.
- Man, that's good cheese.
- It's super mild.
It's not a sharp cheddar.
- That's good.
Smoky.
- It's smooth and creamy.
- It feels like a Cracker
Barrel sorta cheese,
you know, like, your store-bought,
pick it up in the alley.
- This is not an extra sharp
cheddar, I don't think.
It tastes like a medium, mild sharpness.
- $50 cheese?
This is not worth $50.
Maybe, like--
- Yeah, I'm expecting--
- 15.
- Oh!
- It looks like Tillillamook.
- This cheddar looks more expensive.
- 'Cause it looks like it had to be, like,
like, grated with a really fine grater.
- Wow.
- Oh, this has to be the expensive one.
- Yeah, this has, it's so--
- I mean--
- Sharp.
- This is expensive.
- Yeah, it is.
- 'Cause it tastes bad.
- It doesn't taste bad.
- I'm getting all kinda
good flavors over here.
- Oh, wow.
This is rich.
- It's so full-bodied.
It has, like, a whole array of taste.
Like, it's like, sour.
It's a little bit salty.
- It almost tastes expired.
- Oh, this cheddar's good.
- Uh huh.
- I don't care if it's the
most expensive or the cheapest.
'Cause this one is great.
I think it's the expensive one,
but boy oh boy, what a world of flavor!
- Makes your fingers smell bad.
That's how you can tell it's good cheese.
- Smell my fingers.
(sniffing)
- Yup, it's good cheese.
- This is the kind of cheese
that a mouse would like,
fuckin' kill another mouse for.
(mellow music)
- Two.
- Numero dos.
- Two was more expensive.
(bell dings)
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- Dude, cheese club, man.
- That's it.
- I think the second one
was the expensive cheese.
The first one was cheap.
- Agreed.
(bell dings)
- Oh, yeah!
Man, now, but I am upset
that the cheap cheese
isn't that delicious.
- First one, cheap, second, expensive.
- The second one was
definitely expensive cheese.
(bell dings)
Yep.
- 'Cause that shit stunk.
- Mmm hmmm.
- That cheese was weird.
- It was so good.
- Who would pay $50 for that?
- Oh, man, that cheese was great.
- Yeah, wow.
Can't be in a cheese club
and not know the difference.
- Yeah, you have to know sharpness.
- Sorry.
- Expensive.
- I'm gonna smell my fingers
for the rest of the day.
- Expensive cheese is not ordinary cheese.
Expensive cheese is what you buy
for, like, a family around a holiday.
And you all have some
of the expensive cheese
and you're like, "Wow,
that's really good cheese.
"Where'd you get it?"
"Oh, I got it at the cheese market."
"We have a cheese market?"
"Like, yeah, it's on 39th and Broadway."
"Oh, my god, I'm gonna have to go.
"Like, I'll tell my friend Phil.
"He goes all the time, he
can give you some (mumbles)."
Be like, "Thank you so much."
(electronic beat music)